[Musique]
jeannette hubert oui bonjour ça va je
téléphone parce que pour la série
argument je prépare en ce moment des
émissions sur la vie sentimentale des
français au sujet non alors j'avais
imaginé qu'on pourrait aller voir ce qui
se passe du côté des femmes seules ah
oui est banni et comme c'est un peu ton
cas et que tu as he is that is de
réalisatrice de télévision j'ai pensé
que peut-être tu pourrais faire une
enquête là-dessus c'est passionnant mais
cette influence est ce que tu veux
défense et libertés des femmes divorcées
chacun porte il faut montrer la solitude
sentimentale mais il faudrait je crois
trouver des femmes qui en mettant la
quarantaine tu vois les femmes de 40 ans
ce sont celles à qui on a dit qu'elle
devait être désireuse fidèles et des
mères atteintes il et toi tu es seul
pourquoi je suis seul parce que comme
beaucoup je suis une femme divorce et
qu'il l'a choisi de dire bon choisit pas
de divorcer en général quand on y va on
sait que c'est quelque chose qui n'a pas
très bien réussi je crois je crois qu'au
départ une femme bon elle se marie et
elle croit être mariés pour le restant
de ses jours et puis et un incident de
parcours et puis on se retrouve tout
seul et qu'il a elle fait partie du
grand lot des femmes seul coup et après
bah j'ai trouvé ça finalement pas mal
parce que moi le divorce au fond ça m'a
libéré
malgré tout ça m'a libéré parce que
quand j'étais mariée j'ai été dans
l'ombre du mari bien gentil
un coin je ne disais rien je ne
participais que de loi et puis le jour
il a fallu me bagarrer avec tous les
problèmes
ça m'a fait du bien je suis devenu moi
je devenu moi même je vais bien qu'au
début bon bah ça a été très dur il ya
des problèmes matériels mais ça comment
les allées problèmes matériels donc lé
problème affectif il ya bon bar branché
soi et puis y'a pas de chaussettes qui
traîne
selon hrw des jeunes devant une assiette
vivre tout comme star mais après bah ça
m'a fait énormément dit allez vous êtes
une femme seule pourquoi c'est difficile
de dire enfin - cherche pas ça va on est
seul
vous êtes une mère vous avez un enfant
oui vous n'êtes pas mariée donc vous
êtes une femme seule mère célibataire et
ça c'est une situation vous avez choisi
où elle vous a été imposée par la vie je
prends je ne suis pas d'être seul même
parfois
ça arrive comme ça semble que soit
imposé je ne sais pas quoi vous dire
et vous avez organisé votre vie comment
alors je touche je le connais très bien
on cherche des enfants français ne vous
vivez tout ce chemin je vis à vis depuis
70 ans je mes enfants sont grands
étudiants maintenant mais oui mais vous
êtes seul semble se remarie parce que
pourquoi sou est un sou ce temps je n'ai
pas je n'ai pas de m'arriver je voudrais
bien vous êtes vivant comment êtes vous
exactement
mais il s'est paré oui je pourrais
peut-être être ce qu'on a mis une femme
indépendante
fabre à vous faire drôle de retrouver
fille oui bien sûr ça me rappelle
beaucoup de choses j'ai passé beaucoup
de temps ici j'ai passé beaucoup de
soirées
[Musique]
qu'elle vous entrave bien voilà je suis
mariée pendant cinq ans et j'ai une
petite fille
et puis ça n'a pas marché alors j'ai
divorcé et je me suis retrouvé seul et
ça ça a été terrible de me retrouver
seule c'est ce qui me faisait le plus
peur en fait t'as jamais problèmes de
solitude problèmes de solitude oui mais
à partir les enfants on a déjà moins de
problèmes de solitude
et puis quand on éteint quand on
travaille on ne croit pas de problème de
celui qu on a toujours des amis on a
toujours des gens qui viennent vous voir
ou qui on va voir le métier ça n'a pas
rempli sa solitude toi aubin au départ
je crois que le métier ça m'a fait
beaucoup de bien parce que j'ai un
métier qui m'intéresse moi si j'avais
été une dactylo ou si j'avais pas eu de
métiers du tout s'il avait fallu comme
certaines à les faire déménager les
autres parce qu'il y en a qui savent et
bien là ça m'aurait sûrement poser deux
des problèmes mais à partir du moment où
on a un métier qui vous intéressent que
je crois que on peut s'affirmer de cette
manière la charge suis sûr que si tu
avais pas fait ce métier toi tu aurais
peut-être qu'il serait peut-être marié
et te récompenser tu compenses abba
sûrement en tombant de mariage si on
peut parler le métier
oui alors vacances et tandis que moi
c'est le contraire dont j'étais mariée
j'ai eu des enfants
je commençais un peu à travailler puis
je me suis aperçu que ce travail ils
pouvaient très bien remplaçe remplacer
ce que je ne trouvais plus que je
n'avais plus la vie d'une femme ce n'est
pas possible
je pense qu'elle n'est pas très
confortable dans le sens matériel du mot
mais elle est contre nature à mon sens
elle est contre nature une femme n'est
pas fait pour vivre seul et je suis
peut-être un peu moins fait que les
autres pourvu l'instant je n'ai pas de
métier je n'avais pas de métier
particulier donc j'ai des mâts liberté
retrouvée voulu attaquer tous les sujets
que j'avais laissé dans l'ombre qui
m'intéresse c'est ce que j'ai fait
d'ailleurs que vous faites comme effet
une lentille piste
enfin je crois pour moi pour mon cas de
quatre semaines que d'avoir travaillé et
d'avoir participé à la vie à apporter à
mes enfants et à moi même beaucoup plus
de choses que si j'étais resté une femme
à la maison
vous êtes sûrement douilles oui suis
toujours aimé faire ça de broderie le
tricot du crochet
faire de modèle et c'est un travail qui
vous prend combien de temps par dans la
journée je commence à 9 heures du matin
et je finis à 6h30 peu près comme tout
le monde mais alors qu'est ce que vous
faites de votre office pendant semble
arrivent à l'école
alors le soir bien sûr c'est dur parce
qu'il faut qu'il reste et les garderies
et après il ya la télé est alors comment
vous êtes vous me dites que vous avez
bien organiser votre vie alors comment
vous élevez votre enfant toute seule
qu'est-ce que tu dire le samedi dimanche
m'occupe de lui et puis la semaine de
façon à l'école le plus dur c'est faire
le lit des sceaux le sport parce que
origines ans avait toujours un peu tard
quel âge at il
six ans et demi et le sel de principe le
personnage principal de votre lui oui
bien sûr vous n'avez jamais eu envie de
par exemple de ne pas la voir
non non parce que vous tombiez
honnêtement houkes toujours s'arranger
si on est bien quelque chose pour petit
lavoir
oui mais je trouvais que j'avais lâche
d'abord et puis ensuite une situation et
un appartement alors que patrice otha
pas la voir les enfants
si les enfants cette intéressante si
vous lui n'était pas chez vous non je
n'ai pas eu suffisamment près de -2
reste le plus peiné avec ce commerce
pouvait pas la garder ensuite j'ai un
métier pour lequel je me lève très bonne
heure le matin et je ne pouvais pas mon
équipe et elle était trop jeune et
maintenant que vous allez avoir vu
maintenant maintenant je vais la
reprendre la rentrée je leur prends j'ai
une dame dans la maison qu'ils pourront
garder le matin
ils voulaient d'autres non pourquoi
parce qu' un enfant me suffit vous
n'êtes plus femme que maire je crois des
enfants devant tard et act devant ta vie
tu feras millions quelle réaction
je vais vous dire moi j'ai deux fils et
une fille les deux fils
finalement c'est toujours le même
problème sont amoureux de leur mère bien
sûr et très jaloux alors devant ma vie
de femme et pas il était très jeune et
il fallait toujours donné des
explications dire avec qui il sortait
des choses comme ça titles et de leur
expliquer bois jours avec mon fils aîné
on a une grande explication lui
racontant que la horde est sa mère
j'étais aussi une femme et qu' il
fallait bien que je rencontre des hommes
etc
il a très très bien compris vraiment
très libre maintenant le deuxième fils
est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
exclusifs et puis dans des explications
si j'en appelais ce pas il donne son
opinion plus facilement et
bon bah je sais pas le choc et puis
c'est tout les âmes qui rentre le ventre
vie par rapport à votre fils on vient de
quand même c'est dire aux dépenses et
aux hausses et des amis et des amis
bombe
rihanna qui édicte qui reste ça arrange
tout ça quoi mais jamais de problème
chez jamais problème toute façon je ne
change pas les hommes tous les jours
votre fils n'est pas jaloux des alors
les hommes qui viennent doit être jaloux
très et ça se manifeste comme c'est dire
si lent landes lui plaît ça s'arrange
très bien c'était là c'est là que je
compte plus moi je suis plus rien il
devient son copain et puis
c'est comme ton moi ça ça vous ennuie
non non d'ailleurs on se sent plus
embêtant c'est le contraire que je
n'accepte pas c'est le jour j est
amoureuse et il accepte ballon et que je
suis ça sent plutôt embêtant ça pose
parfois comme un des problèmes et je
peux évidemment pas mariés pour faire
plaisir à mon fils
malgré mes enfants j'ai une vie de femme
mais jeudi au départ que j'aurais jamais
sacrifier mes enfants pour par exemple
pour un autre si tu rencontrais un homme
maintenant qu'ils te demanderai de
refaire ta vie avec lui tu tu
accepterais je ne crois pas je veux bien
avoir un homme comme ami je veux bien
avoir un homme comme ça temps en temps
enfin constamment mais pas tout le temps
à la maison mais je crois pas que six
portraits de vivre dans l'ombre de ses
thèmes comme une tare j'crois d'avouer
qu'on dise elle ou qu'on a des moments
de des moments espèce de désespoir d'une
forme de désespoir
c'est une tare d'aix
un peu j'ai l'impression que beaucoup de
femmes le considère en tout cas sous cet
angle ou beaucoup en tout cas ne veulent
pas l'avouer mais beaucoup le
considèrent sous cet angle si elle était
sincère donc il leur faut un homme dans
la vie la femme plus plus qu'un homme a
besoin d'être entouré
parce que la femme est essentiellement
dépendantes
c'est mon opinion way à dépendre
sur le plan financier sur différents
plans physiologiquement elle n'est pas
le même constitution que les hommes
professionnellement elle ne peut pas se
défendre comme un homme
j'ai commencé à aller danser c'était
pour moi devenu presque une nécessité
parce que je ne voulais pas rentrer chez
moi je n'avais pas envie je trouvais ça
c'est l angoisse quand je rentrais que
et de retrouver personnes qu a dit me
retrouver seule alors je venais danser
le soir après votre travail oui je
venais c'était le soir surtout parce que
c'est là surtout que ça faisait d'être
seul
alors souvent je venais au début je
venais avec des amis et puis après
souvent ses amis ne pouvait pas ainsi de
suite et je me disais bon ben ce soir tu
vas te coucher
et puis finalement c'était plus fort que
moi je pourrais pas je mets bizier et
puis je venais je venais ici je me
sentais je me sentais pas seuls quoi je
vous sentiez pas seuls mais enfin est-ce
que c'est agréable pour elle une femme
d'être assise à une table et d'atom cas
monsieur chercher
oui bien sûr
je change
m
je
[Musique]
cette époque ils vous prennent dans vos
bras aux allemands oui c'était pour
sortir une présence sur son sac et me
manquait alors il ya des histoires je
venais ici juste je restais assise je ne
pensais pas c'était pas qu'ils aient des
forges danser et j'avais besoin de
quelqu'un à côté de moi souvent je
sortais avec des cas que t'es pas
toujours intéressant parce que j'avais
besoin de de ne pas être seule est alors
comment ça se passait bien je le voyais
une fois deux fois puis je m'apercevais
vraiment que je me posais des questions
pas pourquoi j'étais sorti avec ses
valeurs mais avant votre mariage vous
aviez eu des verts non non juste mon
mari et parce qu'il vous avait laissé
tout d'un coup et s'était alors qu'ils
ont les mots crûment c'était pour le
physique ou c'était pour la présence
c'était pour la présence finalement vous
leur demandiez même pas de monter avec
vous comme on dit vulgairement n'avait
pas besoin de ça j'avais besoin qu'ils
soient avec moi quoi je sortais on a le
cinéma et tout mes jeux
souvent ça n'allait pas plus loin parce
que ça ne m'intéressait pas mais
quelquefois il m'arrivait d'amener des
garçons chez moi comme ça le but de leur
faire à manger parce que j'avais besoin
d'eux c'était une nécessité quoi de me
retrouver avec quelqu'un
les amis que j'avais en commun les amis
du couple by son parti vise personne
voulait s'occuper de moi tout le monde
s'en laver les mains être comme ça et
puis comme je me suis retrouvé à
travailler de la seule personne qui
m'aidait c'est une femme qui est
vraiment ma sortie de ma solitude de mes
problèmes qui m'a redonné goût à la vie
et qui m'a entraîné dans la vie quoi
donc d'accord et les couples et quand je
suis seule femme dans sa chaîne ap
je trouve personnellement pourquoi parce
qu'en un corner 3 il y en a toujours un
qui un peu à l'écart qu'on ait 5 c'est
pareil c'est toujours ça va toujours par
2,2 quoi donc vous pensez que vous êtes
dans une situation à la roma non non
mais vous collomb mais mal mais enfin on
n'a pas la même vie quand même que le
couple pendaison des trucs entre eux que
moment je lis je connais pas et vous en
avez envie
je ne sais pas honnêtement je ne sais
pas je crois pas non si elles sont amies
d'un couple elles peuvent présenter un
intérêt un peu de déversoir pour pour la
femme de ce couple pour l'homme la chose
est beaucoup plus ambiguë mais de toute
façon c'est elle qui rentrera celle le
soir parce que noir à l'envi de troubler
ce ménage unis ou pas derrière mais qui
éventuellement sera un peu désordonné du
fait qu'elle l'ait fréquentera
régulièrement
allô allô bonjour ça va mieux
oui qu'est ce que tu fais ce travail
non parce que comme je m'ennuyais voulez
savoir ce que tu faisais ce choix oui
résultats tant pis pourquoi moi je suis
à nouveau rien c'est pour ça non je
voulais simplement bon c'est sûr je
voulais pouvoir mais si tu es pris ça ne
fait rien dans sa taille alain vous est
donc heureuse autre de votre vie
solitaire
on y suit bien disait heureuse une
souffrance ça c'est encore d'autres
choses
qu'est-ce que ça le bonheur je ne sais
pas c'était pour dire qu'est ce que
c'est être bien c'est déjà pas mal
jetons mais comme dit je suis bien c'est
quoi je suis bien je suis bien dans ma
peau c'est à dire je te faisais mon
travail j'ai je mets appartement je
m'engage chez je m'ennuie pas arriver là
maintenant brisé mais regardez la
télévision bien sûr vous allez au cinéma
très rarement
est-ce que vous allez tout seul au
restaurant non
non tu te rends souvent je mène souvent
mon fils au restaurant chinois
et puis on en mange avec des amis je
vais dans un restaurant on mange bien
que vous êtes très très gros manques
mari vous n'allez jamais au restaurant
tout seul non jamais je me sentais très
mal à mon aise ailleurs le sel dans un
restaurant donc il vous faut toujours
quelqu'un à côté de vous que ça soit
c'est un homme ou une femme
vous aimez la santé un homme la plupart
du temps c'est un homme alors je ne vais
jamais au cinéma avec une femme
j'entreprends eu d'activité uniquement
avec une amie vous voyez non pas du
temps j'ai un partenaire qui
m'accompagne au cinéma ou théâtre veut
pas arriver une changer de partenaire
sous prétexte que j'avais besoin d'un
partenaire pour aller dans une soirée en
général j'ai un groupe d'amis dont
certains éléments me serve deux
partenaires pour le cinéma au théâtre
xterra ils ont chacun d'ailleurs souvent
leurs fonctions assez précise ah bon
alors il ya le monsieur pour le cinéma
un petit peu le monsieur pour le dîner
au restaurant un petit peu oui
il faut par conséquent je crois usé de
deux personnalités qui s'adapte bien à
l'activité ou au sport que vous voulez
pratiquer et alors disons un sport
amoureux alors une pratique est commun
c'est une question qui est très très
précises le sport brûlé une chose dont
on est difficile de parler en en 2011
devant ne tombe pas amoureux dagher dans
sa vie un nombre infini de fois même si
on est celle même si on est une femme
seule et en admettant qu on ait un
certain succès on a quand même encore le
pouvoir de décider soi-même mais dans
votre vie l'amour c'est ce qui est plus
important
oui donc après le divorce ou la
séparation
il a fallu retrouver un autre amour
autant que possible il a fallu et vous
envisagé de refaire votre vie le métier
ouais il me semble que non ça doit pas
suffire
parce que pour moi je peux pas en parler
puisque au fond j'ai le métier j'ai des
enfants et des amis mais je crois que le
métier seule salle doit il faut se
donner un but dans la vie bon alors
peut-être que le métier c'est un but
mais il ya peut-être d'autres choses y
en a qui font des syndicats mixtes en a
qui les petits chiens et moi je sais pas
moi il faut dormir but
si on est venu tourner ici avec vous
c'est parce que finalement ce lieu qui
est un lieu uniquement où vous cherchez
des présences vous avez trouvé l'homme
de votre vie oui bien sûr je trouvais
l'homme de ma vie parce que je ne
pensais pas du tout
je venais ici mais je ne pensais pas
qu'un jour je puisse rencontrer
quelqu'un et puis il est vrai qu'un jour
je rencontre un garçon qui me convenait
quoi j'ai vu tout de suite que c'était
un garçon fait pour moi maintenant
imaginez que le garçon je l'avais
rencontré ici avec lequel vous vous clip
qu'est ce que vous faites je pense que
j'y retourne certainement danser parce
que on comble le temps qui est libre de
cette façon là ça devient un engrenage
et on a besoin après tout ça quoi et
pourtant c'est pas je pense que c'est du
temps de perdu
[Musique]